okay so marvel are famous for lacing
easter eggs throughout their movies and
spider-man into the spider-verse is no
different however there was actually one
that could have been staring us in the
face the entire time and it's only with
the release of noah home that we now
could realize what's going on when we
visit the spider cave at the midpoint of
the movie we can see several spiderman
costumes hanging up when the film first
dropped a lot of us saw that there was a
sort of switch up on the iron spider
civil war suit but knowing what we know
now we can actually see that this also
looks a lot like the integrated one from
noe home it looks like sony may have
been inspired by the look of this suit
here and they could have pulled across a
similar design for the new web head
movie rewatching the movie in 2021 when
i noticed this it completely blew my
mind and there's actually way more
easter eggs in the film because of what
we now know the cave is filled to the
brim with suits and this includes the
one from the playstation 4 and 5 game
this also appears in the end credits
amongst all the red ones to the right of
it is the black rubber suit that
spider-man actually used to fight
electro in the comics with and he of
course wears something similar to take
him on in no way home now in the cave
miles also comes across a spider suit
with a red cape on it and this pulls
from the story what if spider-man had
never become a crime fighter this look
was referenced in what if when peter
ended up wearing strange's cape in the
zombie episode and it's also somewhat
being given an r2 in no way home during
the chase scene through the mirror
dimension it also calls back to a moment
earlier in the movie just after the bus
trip when peter b parker tells miles
that spider-man doesn't wear a cape
because it's disrespectful next to it we
can also catch the stealth suit which
was introduced when peter was trying to
evade the spider slayers there's also
the mark ii and in the cave we can catch
the spider buggy interestingly if you've
seen the across the spider verse first
look you might notice that miles has a
model of this in his bedroom kind of
bringing things back to this first movie
gwen also has combo's shoes on whereas
in into the spider-verse she's wearing
ballet slippers perhaps showing that
miles's style rubbed off on her a bit
now the movie's post-credits scene has
oscar isaacs playing spider-man 2099 in
it we watch as he gets a bracelet that
allows him to travel through the
multiverse into any dimension at will
this is somewhat similar to the quantum
realm gps that was introduced in
avengers end game as it allows him to
hop across from reality to reality he
ends up being spider-man 67 and they
have a pointing contest that references
some of the best meme material ever
however this bracelet is clearly very
important and in the across the
spider-verse first look you can actually
catch gwen wearing it as she sits in
miles's room throughout into the
spider-verse all of the spider-men and
women had to get home because they kept
glitching but i think this device will
probably stabilize them so that come the
next movie they'll be able to remain in
certain realities now gwen also opens up
miles's sketch pad to a totally not
creepy picture of her but on the left of
this you can catch a bus ticket from the
hudson valley express this was the bus
that miles got with peter b parker in
the movie and it's nice that he keeps it
in his pad as it clearly meant a lot to
him peter b parker is of course a
massive character in the film and he
invites me at the grave of the peter
parker of this universe however this was
actually foreshadowed earlier in the
movie and in the moment when we see
miles about to start his great
expectations essay we can't see the
original bug just beside his pad on the
cover of this is a man and a child in a
graveyard which of course mirrors peter
b parker meeting miles later on we can
actually catch peter b's healing factor
in full effect during the scene in which
he's tied to a punching bag and if you
look at his eye throughout it you'll
notice that the bruising around it
disappears over time it's a really cool
little detail in it that i think shows
just how much effort the animators were
putting into each scene there's also a
big reveal that doctor octopus is a
woman in this universe but a slight nod
is given to the 616 version as during
the lab plan we can see that there's a
scientist that looks a lot like him
perhaps we all need to examine our own
personal biases now if you're enjoying
the video i'd massively appreciate the
thumbs up and make sure you hit the
subscribe to stick around for marvel
videos like this every week if this is
your first time here i'm your host paul
aka your friendly neighborhood spoiler
man now let's get into the rest of the
easter eggs okay so the movie culminates
with the collider opening up so that
kingpin can come into contact with an
alternate version of his family
throughout this scene we get several
flashes of vanessa and his son and one
of these looks a lot like matt murdock
showing that in one reality his kid is
daredevil there's also an
african-american version of the family
which could be a reference to the
michael clarketon conversion of the
character who appeared as the villain in
the ben affleck daredevil movie now
speaking of daredevil there's a moment
in which kingpin and miles fight on top
of the brooklyn bridge the way this
location looks actually makes it seem
like it was ripped right out of the
intro to the netflix show which kingpin
was of course the main villain of when
the collider starts to activate we can
actually see on a screen that the earth
this movie takes place in is one six one
oh if you're a fan of the ultimate
comics then you'll know that this is
actually the designation that that
universe has ultimate spider-man is
where miles made his first appearance
and he was then brought into the 616
timeline after the events of secret wars
now the number 42 also appears during
several points in the film and there's a
couple of reasons to why this could be
in hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy it
was said that 42 was the meaning of life
and while some fans have assumed it's a
reference to that director peter ramsey
shut this down quite quickly ramsay
stated that it's actually a reference to
jackie robinson who also wore the number
42. robinson was the first black
professional baseball player and ramsay
stated that miles is smashing racial
barriers just in the same way that he
was now in case you missed all the
instances when 42 appears we first see
in the opening title sequence when we
can spot on the back of the spider that
eventually bites miles during this intro
we also get a quick cut of a lottery
ball that has 42 on it and this was
actually the number that allowed miles
to get into the brooklyn visions academy
when peter parker's death is announced
we can also see it at the subway station
4 times square 42 also appears when
miles falls off a building and upon the
way down he knocks a sign which drops
the numbers four and two on the ground
lastly it appears when miles and peter b
parker get the bus and we can see that
the maximum occupancy is 42. the two
versions of peter are pretty much polar
opposites in terms of personality and
whilst the one we first meet is finessed
and practiced peter b parker is kind of
sloppy he's more of a falling with style
kind of guy and this is reflected in the
name badges that the two have the first
peters seems brand new whereas the
ladder is crumbled and messy hinting
towards their differences later peter b
and miles go to a fast food joint
together and pete says that in his world
this restaurant got shut down the peter
we metier is slightly older than the one
we meet in miles's universe so we can
guess that he's a couple of years ahead
in the restaurant you might notice that
they actually scored a c for hygiene
showing that these chumps were slowly on
the way out now miles's uncle aaron's
house is filled with easter eggs too and
in his living room we can catch a
picture that hangs above the sofa if you
look closely at this it actually seems
like it has the words prowler written in
graffiti hinting towards him being the
villain it's here that we get one of my
favorite easter eggs in a movie ever and
we can catch community in the background
on aaron's tv in it is the scene in
which donald glover wears spiderman
pajamas now glover actually plays aaron
in the mcu so this is like a weird
inception of easter eggs with aaron
watching the multiverse version of
himself in a spider-man costume in
homecoming glover also mentioned his
nephew who we now know is miles and as i
say
you know what i say it's all connected
now it's not too long before miles talks
to gwen properly for the first time and
she stumbles over her name and calls
herself wonder this could potentially be
an artist scholar which who is known in
the comics as being a nexus being aka
someone who's exactly the same in every
reality wander is going to be a big
player and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness so it's going to
be interesting to see if this is brought
across to that film after fully
discovering his powers miles comes
across spider-man and the green goblin
duking it out the spider men end up
coming face to face which ends up
triggering their spider senses we can
actually see that miles's spider sense
is initially green and purple before it
changes to blue and red much like
peter's aaron's colors are green and
purple but the fact that they change
shows that miles is no longer going to
be led potentially into a life of crime
by his uncle and he will instead follow
in the footsteps of peter peter climbs
to the switch using a very special set
of moves and he manages to get to the
top by holding onto the cylinders of the
machine later on in the film miles uses
the exact same technique to get to the
switch and though gwen and peter don't
know where he got it from at least we do
and that's an amazing way to end the
movie and we close out with miles
sitting in bed whilst gwen arrives
through another doorway we now know that
this scene takes place a year after the
main events of the film and i can't wait
to see the continuation of it in across
the spider verse now into the spider
verse is one of my favorite comic book
movies of all time and i'd absolutely
love to hear your thoughts on it so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we are in a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the
spider-man 4k trilogies on the 30th of
december and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now save that to
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want emails to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of 2002 spider-man which will
be linked on screen right now even
though the movie's over 20 years old i
promise we found some new easter eggs in
it and i'd definitely love to see you
over there right after this if not
thanks for singing through the video
i've been paul you've been the best and
i'll see you in the next one take care
peace